As I looked through the photos, there were some that were over a hundred years old,...
...some still in the envelope from the processing lab.
I couldn't help but think as a retoucher...
...that I could fix that tear and mend that scratch,...
...and I knew hundreds of people who could do the same.
So that evening, I just reached out on Facebook and asked a few of them,...
...and by morning, the response had been so overwhelming and so positive,...
...I knew we had to give it a go.
So we started retouching photos.
Over time, more photos came in, thankfully,...
...and more retouchers were needed,...
...and so I reached out again on Facebook and LinkedIn,...
...and within five days, 80 people wanted to help from 12 different countries.
Within two weeks, I had 150 people wanting to join in.
Once a week, we would set up our scanning equipment in the temporary photo libraries...
...that had been set up, where people were reclaiming their photos.
The older ladies sometimes hadn't seen a scanner before,...
...but within ten minutes of them finding their lost photo,...
...they could give it to us, have it scanned, upload it to a cloud server.
It would be downloaded by a gaijin, a stranger, somewhere on the other side of the globe,...
...and it'd start being fixed.
The time it took, however, to get it back is a completely different story,...
...and it depended obviously on the damage involved.
It could take an hour.
It could take weeks.
It could take months.